vous déjà marié oui alors oui quand il a
fait sa demande en mariage il a mis sa
ou dans de l'herbe
la vague il a peu long alors vous avez
fait votre demande
je me souviens plus exactement je crois
que je classique je pense avoir été
acheté une bague
il n'est pas la bonne taille qu'on a du
ai'a pour élargir way classique une
bague je crois d'accord normal la
mémoire regardera mais vous en souvenez
vous avez dit veux tu m'épouser
avec une exception peut-être à
l'intérieur j'ai oublié et ouais avec
une jolie phrase à l'intérieur mais vers
quoi
[Musique]
c'est aimer aimer c'est monter plus haut
un truc comme ça romantique on embrasse
damien sargue héros